Hisone's on a date?
What a predicament.
Mr. Ikushima, are you interested...
in Amakasu?
Feelings of love will cause over-secretion
of hormones in her body
and distort her suit size!
Masotan! I'm home!
I brought you a souvenir.
I'm sorry, but secondhand flip phones
are surprisingly expensive.
With my salary, I could only
afford to buy five.
These are tokens
of my appreciation for you, Masotan.
Because of you, I've made friends.
Lots of things have happened,
so I'm enjoying every day.
Thank you, Masotan.
T-They noticed?
I'm sorry, Masotan! I'll buy more
next time, but share now--
A... Amakasu?
Futomomo!
-Calm down!
-Go home, Norma!
Even Akemi is getting riled up.
Are flip phones that delicious?
Oh!
What's your favorite confection?
Uh... Kamome or Tamago!
-What about you, Hitomin?
-Hagi or Tsuki!
Yes!
One, two, three.
You've done excellent work.
I look forward to working with you again.
Excuse me! Who are you?
Whatever.
I've been tricked!